Speaker 1: So there's been some super interesting
testimony this week about reproductive rights
and abortion and care for pregnant women in
the aftermath of Roe v Wade being overturned
by the Supreme Court and the Republicans on
this this congressional panel have been just
embarrassing themselves day after day after
day.
And today, I want to look specifically at
a series of questions from Republican Congressman
Ralph Norman, who represents South Carolina's
fifth District.
He completely humiliated himself with these
questions about post birth, abortion, abortion
after birth, which quite literally just doesn't
exist.
It's not a thing when when a baby dies after
birth.
It's not an abortion.
We're talking about something completely different.
And Renita Shannon Shannon, who's a Democratic
state rep from Georgia and others, did the
best they could to keep up with these absurd
questions and see if you can find the full
list.
Like some of them will be obvious, but see
if you can really find the full list of fallacious
claims by this guy.
You agree.
Speaker 2: With infanticide?
Speaker 4: Well, okay.
Speaker 1: So first of all, do you agree with
infanticide?
Already were.
What?
What are you talking about?
Infanticide.
Are we talking about abortion here or are
we talking about murder when kids are out
in the world.
Speaker 4: Using inflammatory language to
basically describe a situation that does not
happen?
We don't have it being decide happening.
Doctors would not do that and neither would
folks who have carried.
Speaker 2: With a healthy child.
Do you agree if a healthy child is born, that
is that woman's right to decide if it lives
or dies?
Speaker 4: What I think is based on your question,
you have a very low opinion of pregnant people,
because if you think and by the way, the question
you use me, answer the question, I'm answering
it, do you not?
Speaker 2: You want to will tell you.
Speaker 1: You want to, Gary.
Speaker 4: Over witnesses.
What I'm saying to you is nobody would carry
a pregnancy and then decide on a monday because
they are bored that they want to have an abortion.
That's ridiculous.
And it's inflammatory.
You're what you're saying.
You're talking about families who are in tough
situations where folks have been excited about
carrying a pregnancy.
Most of the abortions that happened later
in pregnancy are really tragedies where it's
really a disappointment for everyone involved.
Speaker 2: But you agree with that?
I take it with all those words you do agree
with basically murdering a child after they're
born this mass grave.
Speaker 1: Now, this is supposed to be about
abortion.
This isn't about murdering children after
they're born.
It's quite literally a completely different
question.
Speaker 2: Could you answer that?
Would you just.
Yes or no?
Speaker 4: I have to say, Congressman, how
you just characterize a representative statement
is is extremely inflammatory and the type
of thing that it's dangerous.
And what she's been talking today about, the
threats against crisis pregnancy centers,
which I assume are serious.
Speaker 1: And by the way, crisis pregnancy
centers are places that convince women not
to get abortions are terrible.
Speaker 2: The threats have a limited amount
of time.
Abortion is not let you reclaim it.
Speaker 4: My time all day.
Speaker 2: I'm assuming that you're infanticide.
I would also say that while replying.
Speaker 5: Madam Chair, at this time, Congressman,
as.
Speaker 1: This is generally absurd, now this
guy is an embarrassment to himself, into his
state and to his constituents.
There's no doubt about it.
Nobody supports abortion after birth because
there is no such thing.
Now, all of the questions this guy's asking
are obviously bad faith questions.
The questions are being asked in order not
to be answered.
And I do think that the witnesses could have
been better prepared for how to answer them.
I get that they're bad faith questions they
want you not to answer by making it a bad
faith question so that then you look bad.
I believe the best approach is answer it and
then explain that the question's absurd and
it's a frustrating thing all around to watch
because this guy is such an embarrassment.
I mean, it's so it's hard to imagine a worst
faith line of questioning on what is a very
serious issue.
But he should have been done done for equating
abortion with murder.
Nobody's really even they're talking past
each other in a certain sense.
It's not an abortion because birth happened.
It's a mind numbingly stupid question.
But they should be able to say, no, we're
not for that.
And that has nothing to do with decisions,
very difficult decisions that relatively few
families have to make in the third trimester.
They are two completely different things.
They continue to stretch this cartoon ification
of abortion into, well, is it okay to kill
a child one month after they're born?
What about six months?
Well, what about just deciding at two years
old you're not liking this parenthood thing
to the day.
The question can be answered.
Congressman, of course I'm not for an.
And beside.
And what we're talking about here are, um,
there's, it's not a, there's not a pediatrician
involved.
There's an OB-GYN.
Because what we're talking about here is a
pregnancy.
It's still a pregnancy at seven months, eight
months, etc..
And it's exceedingly rare.
Nobody goes in a week before their due date
and says, you know what?
I want to get an abortion.
Every OB-GYN who has testified over the last
two weeks on that says it never happens and
we wouldn't do it.
Now, could you find someone that would say,
sure, I'll do it?
Probably you could find someone.
It doesn't mean it's even something that's
happening.
But the the the questions are designed for
you to feel like you can't answer them so
that you don't so that Norman can go and say,
since you're not answering, I must assume
you're okay with infanticide.
The entire thing is mind numbingly stupid.
They could have been better prepared.
He's still embarrassing.
He still should be embarrassed.
But they could have been better prepared.